backstreet boys serenade et what I want
it that way is really about plus a
smashing sneak peek of tonight's
Bachelorette and only we're with Beyonce
and jay-z openers sisters Chloe and
house hey friends this is the daily
Denny anyone else fill in the Monday
blues you can be honest well hopefully
this will cheer you guys up some of the
biggest artists on the radio right now
hit KISS FM and iHeartRadio 's Wango
Tango concert in LA over the weekend and
that's where Backstreet Boys performed
their new single don't go breaking my
heart but only after giving our lauren
zima a little sneak preview you just
sing a little bit of the new song for us
can you just sing a minute for us it's
the only one I've got is broken now yes
you guys thank you so much the mean new
music is so exciting tell us what people
can expect because I feel like it's you
guys but it's the new version of you
guys like we feel like don't go breaking
my heart is a good introduction to what
the album will be because it it is the
Backstreet Boys you know it when you
hear it but it's you know brand new beat
28 okay brand new beat new BSB 2018 I'm
excited for that so long as they keep
playing the hits though am i right
because we can't get enough of them and
for others they still don't understand
them Chrissy Teigen recently took to
Twitter questioning the lyrics to the
boy bands classic I want it that way
asking what it actually is you know the
old music though Chrissy Teigen tweeted
and she wanted to go there you guys
explain to us what I want it that way
what those lyrics mean it doesn't it
means whatever yep whatever each
individual's interpretation is is what
it means and Chrissy is obviously a
really big big fan and we love you
thanks for so much love and support but
you know it's one of those songs it
doesn't have to mean anything it just
doesn't it just worked really
different to everyone all right some of
the greatest songs mean nothing
you know sometimes that huh well that
may very well be the case but thankfully
vsb added more clarity and their tweet
back to chrissie quote don't want to
hear you say that you want heartaches
and mistakes or to be two worlds apart
we don't want you to want it that way
that's the way we want it for you not to
want it that way so there you have it
folks you don't want it that way I don't
want it that way and we don't want it
that way for Bachelorette Becca kufran
that's right after re broke things off
with her and probably the worst way
possible its Becca's turn to break some
things in this sneak peak of Becca's
first one-on-one date with 28 year-old
Colorado sales rep Blake
[Applause]
um how did that feel how do you feel
this was quite an experience I feel so
good on my body I feel like it's drained
but in the best possible way it was it
was so fun
I mean you smashed the couch that Arie
broke up with you on tell me about that
I well since that happened I have been
saying this great couch I hate that
Coach didn't you side into users all the
time so the fact that they set that up
I'm like I'm not sure what Little John
has to do with that but can he narrate
every major life moment for me just like
that right a speaking of exciting life
moments sister's singing duo Chloe and
how we are about to embark on a huge
opportunity of their own they are
opening for Beyonce and jay-z
have you heard of them the other run to
tour kicks off in the US next month and
only et was with Pete talented teens who
also star on grown ish before their
sold-out performance at New York music
venue s Obie's how do we stop ourselves
from fangirling I mean she makes it easy
Beyonce is such a gracious human being
and it's easy to be around her and talk
to her it's going to be incredibly epic
I just know they're gonna kill it I
already know that's the spoiler they're
gonna kill you
what I really love about Beyonce is she
always encourages us to be ourselves
completely now y'all already knew I was
gonna go to beyoncé and jay-z's wit
bells and whistles on the bonus I get to
see Chloe nollie - can't wait for that
and can't wait to be back here tomorrow
with you guys with a brand new daily
Denny until then just make sure you're
subscribed to our Channel and if you
like what you saw today prove it with a
like alright thanks guys bye